[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de France 24 este
28 de septiembre se celebró el día de
Acción global por el aborto legal seguro
y gratuito en el marco de la fecha la
red de católica hace por el derecho a
decidir desde América Latina y el Caribe
lanzó mujer hágase tu voluntad una
campaña para defender y reivindicar la
libertad de conciencia la campaña está
respaldada con los resultados que arrojó
su encuesta sobre sexualidad o para
latam y el Caribe
81% de creyentes encuestados creen que
por ley el aborto debería estar
permitido en todos o en algunos de los
casos
70,3% de creyentes afirman que una mujer
que aborta puede seguir siendo una buena
creyente y 81% de los creyentes
consideran que si una mujer necesita
hacerse un aborto porque su vida corre
peligro y si el médico que le atiende es
creyente él debe hacer el procedimiento
María fue consultada para ser madre de
Dios en esta frase inicia el sustento de
este grupo de mujeres que sostienen que
el derecho de las creyentes a decidir
sobre su cuerpo debe existir para
ahondar en estos argumentos la
conversación es vía telefónica con
Griselda mata Linares quienes
coordinadora de las redes de católicas
por el derecho a decidir de América
Latina y el Caribe y nos acompaña desde
el Salvador y también en videollamadas
se suma Paula ascensor velado chaga ella
también es coordinadora de la red de
católicas por el derecho a decidir nos
acompaña desde la paz en Bolivia gracias
a ambas por estar con nosotros en ella
soy y en francés 24 y vamos a comenzar
con las preguntas En qué consiste la
campaña mujer hágase tu voluntad y
comienzo con nuestra invitada desde el
Salvador
Hola Mucho gusto Gracias por esta
oportunidad de poder contar con mucha
energía con mucha felicidad nuestra
campaña de verdad estamos bastante
contentas de poder Mostrar invisibilizar
Y posicionar por supuesto nuestra agenda
política como red de católicas por el
derecho de estudiar de América Latina y
el Caribe esta Campaña en realidad es el
propósito de tenerla es precisamente
para contar ese recorrido que ha tenido
la red por más de 34 años una es una red
que cuenta con 10
países está en 10 países las sedes y
precisamente Busca posicionar promover y
posicionar la defensa de los derechos de
las mujeres especialmente los derechos
sexuales y los derechos reproductivos
desde una identidad como bien lo
menciona
Católica y feminista nosotras tenemos
una propuesta alternativa disidente
somos una dos que defiende a las mujeres
en su derecho a decidir muy bien y sobre
eso sobre eso Griselda Quisiera darle
espacio también a su compañera para que
nos cuente porque ustedes se catalogan
como usted bien lo dice como una
organización disidente y aquí Quiero
preguntarle a Paula sobre sobre esta
opinión Usted cree Paula que cada vez
más creyentes están a favor del aborto
porque todavía sigue siendo un tema tan
difícil de discutir al interior del
cristianismo y de la Iglesia Católica
por ejemplo
Muchísimas gracias Ángela un saludo y
pues Por supuesto que sí creemos que
cada vez hay más personas creyentes que
tienen desde sus necesidades realidades
y vivencias pues las capacidades de
decidir sobre su cuerpo su reproducción
su sexualidad y que están más alejadas
de los preceptos de las jerarquías y
dogmas fundamentalistas que tienen desde
una moral sexual impuesta las iglesias y
en especial la Iglesia Católica vemos
que hay un alejamiento también de la del
dogma o de la doctrina católica de la
realidad desde las personas y las
personas ejercitan su sexualidad de
manera libre y decidida cada vez más
Pero obviamente Esto se debe a que
históricamente también se han ido
sujetando no cierto las personas
a estos mitos a estas dogmas y Estas
ideas que se tienen sobre la sexualidad
además absolutamente vinculadas
solamente al tema reproductivo y dentro
del tema reproductivo limitando a las
mujeres a un rol
como un destino de ser solamente madres
y no tener otras posibilidades bueno
no nos olvidemos que estamos en culturas
donde realmente la presencia religiosa y
esta fuerza de Estas ideas mitos y
creencias Pues hacen eco también en lo
social bueno para allá iba porque es que
muchas veces la religiosidad nos deja
como sin salida a las mujeres porque por
un lado sobre todo los sectores más
conservadores de la iglesia condenan hoy
en día muy fuertemente la utilización de
anticonceptivos
por otro lado sin manera de protegernos
casi que quedaría como ese destino
natural ese mito del destino natural de
la maternidad y cuando llegó llegó y
tampoco podemos hacer nada cuando llega
el momento de finalizar un embarazo de
manera voluntaria sobre todo que ni
siquiera se puede hacer cuando es la
vida de la mujer la que corre riesgo
cuando hay unos casos que que ya en todo
el mundo se han declarado como excepción
Alguien tiene que ceder aquí no sin
embargo el dogma de la iglesia católica
no cambia
pero creemos que tenemos que también
transformar desde nuestras nuevas formas
de creer y que también tenemos mucha fe
y esperanza de que otra forma de Iglesia
También es posible pues desde ahí
trabajamos con estos argumentos también
teológicos feministas y pues creemos que
hay mucha gente que se adhiere y
contribuimos a que estos corazones y
deseos también se muevan desde la
libertad de conciencia desde la
argumentación de la maternidad elegida y
voluntaria y por supuesto también desde
la laicidad de los estados
y sin embargo grupos como el de
católicas por el derecho a decidir son
como una gota en un mar lleno de
creyentes que defienden esta llamada
postura prohibida cuando se habla del
aborto que es una discusión súper amplia
en este momento en América Latina y
quiero volver a Griselda porque dentro
de esta encuesta que uno puede visitar
en internet de católicas por el derecho
a decidir ustedes primero hacen una
evaluación de las opiniones de las
personas sobre los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos sobre A qué edades
deberían empezar todas las tareas de
educación sexual y reproductiva y luego
empiezan a hablar de laicidad y de Cómo
una mujer no deja de ser buena según la
respuesta de los encuestados o no deja
de ser creyente por el hecho de haber
tenido un aborto o por el hecho de haber
decidido por ejemplo planificar porque
es tan importante para ustedes ligar la
educación sexual que No necesariamente
tiene que ver con la religiosidad con
estas opciones que finalmente toman las
mujeres cuando son adultas y fueron
criadas dentro del credo religioso
precisamente porque consideramos que las
mujeres tienen el derecho a vivir su
sexualidad plenamente libre de culpas
libra de miedos y por supuesto una
sexualidad también informada por esa
razón creemos que la laicidad es
importante precisamente porque los
programas políticos deben estar
enfocados en la realidad y las
condiciones de las mujeres pero no
tienen que estar no tienen que mantener
una injerencia de la iglesia o de esos
prejuicios y eso fundamentalismos
religiosos que muchas veces ingieren en
la en las decisiones políticas que se
toman a través de las diferentes
parlamentos a cambiar legislativas
nosotros creemos en que las mujeres
tienen la capacidad de poder vivir su
espiritualidad y poder tomar decisiones
desde ese desde ese amor Y de esa Desde
esa conciencia y es un digamos un pacto
entre ellas y también su diferentes cre
no y creemos que también no necesita no
es no debería de darse o permitirse que
siempre se condene a una maternidad
forzada a las mujeres Nosotros sabemos
en América Latina por ejemplo vamos en
retroceso en función de los temas de
aborto en países en los que no sea
todavía hay una penalización absoluta
del aborto por ejemplo El Salvador y en
ese sentido Pues también la educación
integral de la sexualidad justamente es
una de las de las
propuestas que se lleva desde los
movimientos feministas pero que también
han sido limitadas negadas en en esos
países Paula hablemos sobre cómo se
realizó esta encuesta y teniendo en
cuenta Qué factores pues para que
nuestros televidentes tengan un panorama
más amplio del tema
Claro que sí con mucho gusto esta
encuesta ha sido realizada en el 2021
acompañadas de la casa encuestadora
ipsos con presencia en seis países de la
región entre los que han estado
Argentina Bolivia Colombia
también ha estado Perú Brasil y México
hemos tenido una muestra en total de más
de 6000 personas la mayoría auto
identificadas como personas creyentes la
mayoría también como personas
pertenecientes a la Iglesia Católica y
pues tenemos como un promedio de mil
encuestas por países en los seis países
y pues nos da una mirada obviamente
regional y también algunos resultados
que
nos muestran que en general hay una
tendencia mayoritaria favorable a estos
temas que nosotros planteamos en el
plano de la sexualidad de la religión y
bien pues entonces aquí el llamado al
parecer es para que la que se actualice
sea la iglesia ahora justamente hablando
de la iglesia Quiero preguntarle Paula
si ustedes han recibido alguna réplica
de las autoridades eclesiales Cuál es la
reacción que han recibido desde desde la
iglesia católica
en este momento y de manera específica
no tanto con relación a la encuesta pero
pues sí En algunos momentos la Iglesia
Católica y sus jerarquías
pueden haberse pronunciado en contra a
lo que nosotros perdonamos a lo que
nosotros anunciamos y a nuestras
posturas obviamente críticas disidentes
y esta voz alternativas sin embargo no
hay respuestas oficiales digamos desde
la jerarquías eclesiásticas sin embargo
también hay que entender que la Iglesia
Católica es muy etodología muy diversa Y
pues también dentro de ella hay muchos
grupos de Voces religiosas progresistas
que en todo caso también les parece muy
bien estos datos arrojados los usan
también como parte de muchos argumentos
que buscan una transformación de estos
patrones socioculturales pero también de
las transformaciones internas que debe
haber dentro de la Iglesia Católica eran
con nosotros soy Griselda lunares y
Paula el tesoro velado chaga tendríamos
mucho más para decir sobre este tema
pero dejamos el debate abierto aquí en
ella soy y sobre todo la frase con la
que empezamos la madre de Dios tuvo la
elección de convertirse en mamá Gracias
a ustedes por estar con nosotros y a
nuestros televidentes sigan en Francia
[Música]